I hope you all are ready it may have
been the global day of jihad Friday the
13th but we have this from Reuters us
must be ready for simultaneous Wars with
China and Russia report says the US must
prepare for possible Wars with Russia
and China by expanding its conventional
forces strengthening alliances and
enhancing its nuclear weapon
modernization program a congressionally
appointed bipartisan panel set on
Thursday the report from the Strategic
posture commission comes amid tensions
with China over Taiwan and other issues
of and worsening with Russia over its
invasion of Ukraine another thing that
many people have brought up to us that
came up yesterday was something called
the Samson option considering the
conflict with what's going on with
Israel I think it's particularly
relevant to this story for those who
aren't familiar the Samson option is the
name that some military analysts and
authors have given to Israel's deterrent
strategy of massive retaliation with
nuclear weapons as a last resort against
a country whose military has invaded and
or destroyed much of Israel commentators
also have employed the term to refer to
situations where non-nuclear non-israeli
actors have threatened Conventional
Weapons retaliation such as yaser aret
now what's interesting about that
concept of the Samson option the general
idea being if this so we we have this
Conway of Hamas storming in killing
civilians Israel then starts Target
targeting Hamas uh uh uh uh bases and
weapons Depot and things like this
civilians get caught in the cross they
die we then get fake videos there was a
fake video today apparently of cutter
saying that they were going to cut off
gas supply not real it's been debunked
my understanding but you have threats
from Iran you have Lindsey Graham saying
war with
Iran if there is an invasion of Israel
the fear is that they're just going to
say we we refuse to be destroyed and
they'll fire a nuke at their enemy but I
think the reality is any country with a
nuclear weapon that is invaded and is
facing extinction or or non existence is
going to launch a nuclear weapon so the
fear here is Israel being particularly
vulnerable if they launch a nuke then
what happens I mean it's going to be all
out World War III massive nuclear
warfare yeah I mean when I think about
it the Samson option was essentially the
core of what in the Cold War we called
mutually assured destruction because
mutually assured destruction is the
United States has 10,000 nuclear
warheads and the Soviet Union has 10,000
nuclear warheads and the reason you have
peace is each side makes a public
declaration that if the other side
launches nukes you will do the same and
cause essentially the extinction of
mankind and it's that Mutual fear oddly
enough that keeps both parties
reasonably well behaved now we're in a
postc Cold War era of course but I don't
see why that logic disappears it remains
actually identical except now it has to
be applied you know more regionally or
more locally but why would a country
allow its own Extinction without wanting
to visit exactly the same on the people
who perpetrated that I mean this is a
case where I mean I suppose there's a
certain at a certain theoretical level
you could have well listen they've
already launched these nukes I'm going
to die anyway why should I kill more
people I just need to sit tight and let
myself be blown up but that's not
realistic no one really thinks like that
yeah I mean I I don't know I've never
been through nuclear war but I it's not
just like the nuke hits and then that's
the end like a nuke will set up the
stage for an invasion Like You Can level
the ground level all the defensive
capabilities and then invade the the
city that got nuked like two days later
or something or a day later also there's
Fallout for there's all sorts of things
that happen afterwards that also suck if
you don't immediately it's almost worse
radiation and 48 Hours of Fallout or
something did the Chinese are they
actually uh genetically altering their
soldiers to be radiation resistant we
talked about that there was a report
that they're they've started breeding
genetic super soldiers I mean that's a
scary reality of what's to come and so I
I suppose the concern is not even
nuclear weapons I think that's old
school thinking it is honestly it is
actually crazy to me that most people to
this day are like nuclear weapons I'm
like bro that's a hundred years old
basically basically like they started
developing this stuff 100 years ago
deployed a couple by today standards
weak ones that's kind of scary to think
too yeah and then really I mean what
since the 70s we've had icbms and and
mvs and things like this the US 10 years
ago uh uh funded the a very very small
Megaton Gravity Bomb basically pocket
size version of the fat man and uh we
also have these icbms have hypersonics
but I think people need to understand
that a lot of the research has been in
targeted biological
and the real scary thought is not that
Israel says we're going to fire a nuke
but that they're like we're going to
unleash a virus or something like that
or like an insect plague I think they
people have been using insects also I
mean think let's let's think about this
realistically you've got ethnic conflict
in the Middle East right these are
groups that hate each other based on
their ethnic
Heritage wouldn't they be specifically
trying to Target if if if you've got
groups of people saying that they want
to eradicate is Israel would they not
make weapons specifically to do so if
they had the capabilities they probably
would I I I do believe that it's more
about territory and less about genetics
at at the core I think it's about who
owns that area of the world well right
right but what I'm saying is the
majority of the people in Israel are
Jewish and many of these people in say
Iran or in Gaza Lebanon explicitly say
the Jewish people and so it's not even
about that I mean isn't there on all
sides when it comes to any kind of War
if the US is facing war with Russia
there is there is an incentive be This
Is War man I mean you look at what uh uh
what what what was that Japanese unit in
World War II 731 I think 731 731 they
stuck people's arms into Sub-Zero
temperatures they're they're in a room
they put their arm into a vet or
whatever with sub-zero temperatures and
then pull it out and shatter it with a
hammer to see what would happen yeah
then after the war the US is like we
need those guys over here well it's like
the we did cuz they were sending like
plague fleas and hot air balloons over
here I think one actually landed well
they were doing those bombs yeah they
had the they had the hot air balloons
what are they called I we talked about
yeah we did and they would float in the
jet stream Y and then once they would
start sinking once they got too low then
a bag would drop and it would go back up
crazy and then it would dropping bombs
yeah I mean we just get a small insight
into how nuts these people are just when
we think about gain of function research
I mean just think of something so
explosive as to take highly contagious
viruses and start screwing with them to
make them more lethal to quote study
them and this is going on in
Laboratories all over the world and the
probability of these viruses getting out
when you add up all the Laboratories and
all the procedures is actually pretty
high so it ends up that you create a
worse plague than you started or that
you started out to try to diffuse and
and all of this is this is all in peace
time and now you put in you put in war
and the aggression and the
competitiveness of War and the massive
resources devoted to the military which
is much bigger than the resources
available to the NIH and you can only
imagine what scary stuff is going on
there yeah yeah and and honestly it's
beyond just uh uh biological weapons or
directed energy weapons when the US
during the Manhattan Project nobody knew
what they were doing there was there
were speculation that the US was working
on some kind of technology and uh some
of the speculation was a a laser beam a
death a death ray and some people I I
believe did speculate that there was
going to be a nuclear bomb I think it
was because the the initial publications
of nuclear reactions quantum mechanics
and things like that was like 20 some OD
years earlier so the US started working
on this and theoretically saying like
can we make this explode can we blow it
up big and so people were trying to
figure out what it was right now but no
one knew that's my point right now the
weapons the US has are probably beyond
our comprehension right or I shouldn't
say beyond our comprehension I mean like
we said we' be like oh wow they did what
it's just
that if they I will put this way I bet
they could come out and be like yes the
large you know International
multinational military industrial
complex corporations have a weapon that
is based on you know X you'd be like wow
I never thought of that you might I
might say that there the weapons that
are being used now are beyond our
perception that might be that might be
an interesting way to look at it because
like lasers you don't see them they're
just heat it's just heat that you can't
see what I mean is like we're not even
thinking of what they've already
developed so we're talking about like
biological we like that was 20 years
molecular disassembly through vibration
I mean skin just fall off just by
hitting them with a low frequency stuff
like that or just like renders you not
able to think at all well look at the
the the was it the Havana syndrome yeah
Havana syndrome they thought that was a
weapon I guess they're saying it's not
now but people would hear like a loud
hum and then they would lose they start
losing vision in one eye and getting
headaches and they couldn't think
straight I mean interestingly with every
major war the magnitude the scale the
hor horrific nature of it was completely
unanticipated Before the War I mean
World War I nobody had any idea that it
would last as long that trench warfare
would you'd have people who are
basically fighting for 2 and a half
years for like 50 yards of of land uh
and you're sitting in a trench Knee Deep
in water you sleep there uh people are
being shot up and their bodies then just
dissolve right next to you and and so
just the sheer hor horror of it and and
you know the thing about it is we
haven't had that kind of a war now in
all of our lifetimes cuz we have to go
back back to World War II for a
comprehensive War so it makes people in
a sense lose sight of what war actually
means the first one first world war was
the machine gun no one anticipated the
machine gun so they'd get up with their
rifles and run towards what was
assumably dudes with rifles as they had
done for thousands hundreds of years and
then the machine gun changed that and
then World War II you have air air power
like the the force of an air bomber
changes in there everything and now what
do we have we have space lasers who
knows what we got this is the story well
yeah China does have space lasers not
say they're weaponized but we know for a
fact that story you could drop stuff
from orbit readily it's just getting up
getting up there right but uh what
you're describing in is the story of
basically every war right so uh uh we've
talked about Gettysburg the Confederates
were using muzzle loaded uh rif rifled
muskets and the union had adopted breach
loading rifles with cartridges so the
union is firing every 10 seconds and the
Confederates are firing every 30 seconds
to a minute Napoleon no question know if
Napoleon had new tech other than like if
the Dutch Tech that the Dutch didn't
have or tech tech that the the austrians
didn't have or whatever but he had he
invented the core system the core you
know the core military core where he'd
divide uh command amongst his generals
and give all of his Marshals basically
they were called uh total Authority
amongst themselves and so they were able
to move much more rapidly and and
respond to Battlefield activity much
more fluently right right uh absolutely
I mean there's a there's a very
interesting uh study of Western
Civilization which tries to understand
how the West became the dominant world
power which it has been over the past
500 years and the argument was that the
Western countries were always fighting
and as a result each side had to keep
innovating in terms of warfare to get
the edge over the other guy whereas you
think of other take American Indian
societies for example now there was
tribal Warfare and so on but it was
conducted kind of the same way whereas
what was happening in the west is one
guy you know you start off and everybody
you have a normal caval then one guy
starts inventing a crossbow and the
other guys to develop a shield and then
the knights start putting on Armor and
so there's constant Innovation that
shows why the power in the west keeps
moving I mean it belongs to the
Portuguese in fact that's how the
Portuguese got to India they were the
leading power in the west at one time
then the Spanish then the French then
the English that Hitler's actually basic
point was he was kind of envious of the
fact that the British and the French had
sort of dominated the world in the
previous 100 years he's like what about
the Germans so a lot of Hitler's
aggression was motivated by that he
actually admired the British Empire he
wanted to create one well with Europe
you you have a peninsula and with with
expanding population density the
Mediterranean is is warm weather so
there was there was uh more abundant
food it was easier to grow food you end
up with people with more free time then
you get population density with close
proximity and conflict over resources
once winter starts rolling in so you
have all this fighting
because exactly as you described you get
Innovation there was one uh story I read
where I can't remember what battle it
was but uh one side made their arrows
with very tiny notches so that the when
they fired the arrow towards the enemy
the enemy could not put the knock or
whatever it's called the notch or knock
or whatever it's called into the string
and they couldn't fire it back but
theirs with the larger hole they could
pick up so they could use both arrows
but like that kind of innovation now
here's the thing about North America
farely populated when Native Americans
would fight it would be brutal but they
could also flee so we see this in
natural selection as well it's why uh
birds are less likely to be aggressive
because they can just leave flight and
in the lit in the sense of like avoiding
a fight not in the literal sense
avoiding a fight takes less energy than
engaging in a fight so burrowing animals
tend to be more vicious and flying
animals tend to be less vicious for that
reason right it's not absolute right
abits are not particularly vicious you
back them in a corner they might nip at
you but go their strategy was just to
have lots of themselves which is kind of
funny or their evolutionary pressure and
they didn't have armor the Native
Americans as far as I know I don't know
think that they they focus they didn't
build castles they didn't build
defensive bastions they didn't really
that I know of uh build armor and things
like protective because it was always
like attack and Retreat attack and flee
and run away it's such a massive land
mass with with tremendous Farmland in
the Great Plains that you didn't have to
have such uh uh dramatic fighting over
resources and uh effectively you could
leave if if they were chased out and the
land was taken and by a Waring tribe
they would run away and they didn't I
don't know I assume that they didn't
Farm not as readily as they did in
Europe uh they were more hunter
gatherers well you had two types you had
the sedentary farming tribes and the the
Hopi the Pueblo but of course they were
always at the mercy of the kamanchi and
the Apache and the nomadic more vicious
uh Tomahawk carrying uh tribes which
were which would have their way uh with
these other I mean Columbus noticed this
when he got here he the first Indians
that he ran into were really nice guys
and Columbus went back to you know he
went back to Spain and he's like these
people are like they're like Adam and
Eve they're like living in the Garden of
Eden the second time he came back he he
ran into a whole different crew and he
and and in fact a lot of the allegations
against Columbus OH Columbus turned
vicious and so on well the reason he
turned vicious is he ran into tribes
that were into Mass Slaughter
and uh that opened his eyes thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net